This might be one of the most
beautiful camps I've ever...
had the pleasure to stay at.
( Hilaree laughing )
( applause )
Only at this camp
at 18,200 feet,
were we finally on our route
which is totally insane.
And we were only, maybe a
thousand feet below the summit
when we were like,
"Oh, yeah! This is it!
We're definitely here. We're
where we're supposed to be."
You can see how narrow this
ridge is that we're camped on.
And it was just big
enough to set up
a three-man tent and
a two-man tent.
And this was where
a lot of hard decision
and human dynamic
kind of came into play
and I also think
that's what's, this is what
makes this trip so interesting.
And... so hard at the same time
was that essentially we
knew from this point on
we knew we only had food
for two, maybe three days.
And... we didn't
have the resources
for all five of us
to go to the summit.
And the climbing was only
getting more complicated
as we went higher and...
a lot of back and forth
went on at this point.
I think, Emily knew that she was
gonna be staying at the camp
and not climbing higher.
And at one point early on,
I was...
sort of talking with Mark and
they were very clear that
they didn't have
confidence in me climbing.
They did not want me
to go to the summit.
And it was very hard for
to me to swallow that.
I felt really strong, I was very
motivated to go to the top.
I thought a lot of the
trip was about Mark and I
and our partnership and so...
to be told that was very
difficult, to say the least.
What followed was kind
of this back and forth.
Eventually we... I was going
to be on the climbing team
but something just, just
wasn't sitting right with me.
And that night,
I went to bed and
just to give you a little bit
of like, what was going on
while we're trying to make
these decisions is that
the wind on this
ridge was blowing
it was gusting, up to
70 miles an hour.
And we were really
exposed on this ridge
so it's coming under the tents
it feels like you're
gonna get blown away.
We all had every
stitch of clothing on
that you could possibly...
that we had!
And we're still kind of
these shivvy-bivvys.
We're still freezing.
We knew we only had enough
food for three days.
We had very limited ropes and
no idea how far it was
to the summit, still.
So, kind of, all
these pressures.
We were, you know, almost
40 days into this expedition.
We'd all probably lost like
I'd lost ten pounds off
of this frame already.
Mark was like, bone thin and...
we knew we still had, you
know, two weeks to go.
So, there was a lot of stress.
And it was probably one of
the hardest decisions
I've ever made.
But, there had been this...
seed of doubt
placed in me from
the day before.
And over the night
it just grew and
I felt like our trust as a team
had really been compromised.
And my place in the team,
was to be with Emily.
And I made the decision...
you know at like,
five in the morning
to not go to the summit
and Cory took my place
and the three of them
left right after.
So, this is the
three of those guys
heading out from our high camp.
So, just to give you an idea
of the complicated
climbing that followed.
We were at 18,200 feet.
They climbed for
eight hours that day
and they gained about 400 feet.
And these are like,
pretty good climbers.
They didn't get very far.
And they went up and down.
That's why it was kind of
like the jungle.
It's like going up these ridges
and down these ridges.
And they set up a two-man tent
and the three of them
slept in that.
And this is just a
short video about
what their climbing experience
was like going towards
the summit.
( instrumental music )
Conrad: Now we're on the south
side of the sun.
We can see our objective.
We have high hopes.
It's hard, it's real climbing.
This is alpine climbing.
( wind rustling )
But meanwhile, Emily and I
were still at high camp.
And we were there for four days
on this tiny little
ridge, trying to
just survive and
make it through.
And Emily is pretty cheerful.
She was trying to cook these,
like scones
that are supposed to be
cooked on a stove on...
on the top of our pot and
they never cooked, obviously.
We ate them anyways and totally
had horrible stomachs after.
So in those four days...
we stopped eating
after the first day
because we were trying to
save food for the guys.
We realized as we
walked around the tent
that the guys had taken
all of the ropes.
And this was totally
an accident...
with all the conditions
and everything going on
none of us thought it through.
But, we had no ropes and it was
really dangerous climbing.
And if those guys didn't come
back, we had no way to get down.
So, it was... pretty terrifying.
At one point I sent--
and I'll get into some of
our communications.
But, our communications
were so crazy
that we were communicating with
Emily's dad in the United States
and he would call on a satellite
phone to Taylor at base camp.
And at one point, I texted him
"So, you know, we don't
have any ropes.
So, if you could
tell Taylor that
that if we have
to come down
it's gonna be, it might
take us a while."
And I'm like, "Oh my God, I'm
writing this to Emily's dad!"
And he writes back and
he's like, "What?"
( audience laughter )
I was like, "Yeah!"
But, this is a, this a
little video from Emily
about base camp,
or high camp.
This is the fourth day
that we are stuck...
at 18,000 feet.
In this tent, in the wind...
Going a little stir crazy.
But, this is our view.
I'll show you.
( wind rustling )
That's Tibet.
That's Burma.
This is where base camp is.
So, Emily and I watched...
she had like, her phone and
you could see that,
sort of, a solar panel
We were watching like, episodes
of "Portlandia" on our phone.
( audience laughter )
Laughing hysterically and since,
I've tried watching them at home
and they're so not... as funny.
But, they were really
funny up there.
So, Mark made the decision,
when he was at...
you know, I think the high
point was about 18,800 feet.
He thought it looked like
the summit was still
almost a thousand feet
above them
which would definitely make it
the highest peak
in Southeast Asia.
But, they turned around.
And it was a really
tough decision
but, it was definitely
the right one.
We were too strung out.
And Emily and I had already
made the decision that
as soon as they were back
we were gonna set up the
two-man tent.
The next morning, early, we were
gonna grab one of the ropes
grab as much gear, as we
could and take it down.
Because, we still had to set up
anchors all the way down and
do all these rapps in order to
get back to base camp, rappels.
So, we got up at about
five-thirty in the morning
and the two of us started
heading down the mountain.
And, the relief I felt, as soon
as we started walking down.
It's indescribable. And I think,
I've thought about it a lot.
I think it was the first time,
in over a month
that we were walking on terrain
and knew where we were going.
So, if you can imagine that.
We were like, retracing our
steps for the first time
since we'd landed in Yangon.
We were setting up anchors
and rapping down
that huge north face,
trying to get down.
Finally, we walked
down to camp one and
we had a little stash of food
and we had all this extra fuel.
And we got totally like,
crazy like, maniacal
and we're like,
burning everything...
that was in our packs.
Which was sort of funny.
But, we ate a little
bit of the food
and we went down to base camp.
And not too long after,
the guys came down, because
you know, all the ropes were
in place and everything.
And, it was like,
this crazy re-entry.
All of a sudden, we were like,
sitting on dry ground.
There was a fire.
We were eating real food,
instead of freeze dried food.
And then, slowly as we
were walking out like,
things from civilization
started coming back at us.
Like, I remember the first time,
like, sitting in a chair.
All that kind of stuff hits
you as you're coming down
when you've been
that stretched out.
And this picture, was kind of
at the height of how
hungry we were.
I mean, these villages
don't have anything.
So, we were just,
we had basically
two bowls of rice a day
for ten days over
130 miles of walking.
This picture is awesome
because everything sounds
so grim and desperate.
But really, we laughed a lot.
And Emily, is totally
smoking a cigarette
and drinking rice wine
out of this bottle
that we were sharing
with the locals
because it was the first
alcohol we'd had in six weeks.
We hadn't had
showers in a month.
Emily doesn't smoke, by the way.
Neither of us, none of us, do.
But, like, smoking really helps
if you're absolutely starving.
And we were.
So, that might
be the only cigarette
I've ever seen her have.
Just saying that, because
she doesn't smoke.
Finally, we made
it back to Putao.
And we had showers and
we were so strung out
that I literally
like, saw the shower
and freaked out.
I couldn't take a shower.
I... pulled out my
disgusting sleeping bag
and laid it on this
bed with nice sheets
and I slept in my sleeping bag.
And I didn't take
a shower for like
24 hours after getting
back to Putao
because I just didn't
know what to do.
Like, my clothes were like,
part of my skin at that point
and so I was afraid to
kind of, take them off.
But, this was post shower.
Emily even put on some make
up and we were drinking beer.
It was really
surreal, basically.
So, just one more video
kind of, taking us
out of the mountains.
( instrumental music )
( speaking in Burmese )
Wow, you guys, oh, my God!
Decompressing a little?
( speaking in Burmese )
( unclear ) are not easy...
( instrumental music )
Hilaree: Full stripping down
of all the mirrors
and the most stretched out and
beaten down I've ever been.
So, I'm gonna go back to this
picture that I started with.
Because, now you have a better
idea of why we were like that.
I'm just gonna, kind
of, end with a quote.
This is a quote from Mark Twain.
"Twenty years from now
you'll be more disappointed
by the things that you didn't do
than by the ones you did do.
So, throw off the bowline,
sail away from the safe harbor
catch the trade winds
in your sails.
Explore. Dream. Discover."
And then to add, in my own words
kind of what I learned
from this trip is--
Don't let the fear
of failure stop you.
Fear of failure is a
really powerful thing.
It's paralyzing at times.
But, there's no courage,
without fear.
So, embrace the fear, love
the suffering, take a risk
laugh at yourself, a lot.
And dive in and try
'cause, you'll never have an
adventure without a little fear.
That's it. Thanks!
( applause )